- If I became your full time manager,
and we started business together,
and this was my life,
literally the first
thing I would say to you
is 42 year old white girls.
- 42 year old white girls?
- You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
("We Fly High" by Jim Jones)
How are you guy all doing?
Good?
Have you been, Boyd?
- I'm doing good.
- [Gary] I like Mozzy a lot.
- Grinding and grinding.
I'll be functioning with my boy, Gary Vee.
I don't know if you all familiar with him.
Motivational speaker.
That nigga said, man, put your head down,
work for seven years straight.
Just put your head down,
Fuck what everybody else doing.
Seven years straight.
And that's how you
accomplish shit in a year.
- What Mozz says is smart.
- Yeah, I like the way he's thinking.
- He's smarter than most people.
In this industry,
from an independent standpoint,
the way he goes about
acquiring his artists,
it's pretty dope.
- It's really interesting.
I met with Mozzy,
then I met with the CMO,
and it was just an interesting night.
This was the last night in LA.
And I was laying there,
and I was like, "Man, it's so crazy to me
"how I grew up,
"how much more I associate with Mozzy
"than I do with like a Fortune 500 CMO."
It's why I'm excited about
tonight's conversation.
My ability to plug the two environments,
and I did it when I
first started my company.
I was more from startup
world, Silicon Valley.
You know, Facebook, Twitter, Tumblr.
And I got into the big brands.
And now they know,
'cause it's 10 years later,
but then they didn't.
And to me, like,
the reason Snoop Dogg is
like the face of a game show,
like Joker's Wild,
like if you would've told me,
the 19 year old version of me
that fucking the guy that I
just listened to on The Chronic,
is gonna be like fuckin',
like Anderson Cooper.
I would've laughed you out of the room,
but that's what happened.
And I don't think people
actually understand
how this shit actually
plays out, which is,
this is the middle.
The middle is when Wiz
Khalifa can walk into
a boardroom with no T-shirt on,
and not a boardroom like I'm
trying to get an album deal
from Death Row,
no, no, like actually Coca-Cola.
That's the middle.
The beginning is when this all
came up in the 80s and 90s,
when it was like what it was.
This is the middle.
The next part is that
you have the leverage.
The internet is a much bigger
thing than people realize.
It will only reward what
the people fuck with.
What happens next is
you have the leverage.
And that's where a lot of your decisions
need to come from over the next 20 years.
Because even though we're a little older,
we're still young as fuck.
Warren Buffet didn't
start making real money
until he was like 63.
And guess what?
How old are you?
- 42.
- What the 26 year old
version of us doesn't realize,
is we're the exact same fucking
dude in our heads right now
that we were 16 years ago.
I'll be talking to like a 20 year old,
and be like, we should,
like as if we're the same.
Right?
You feel it, right?
Well here's where I'm going with that.
I already know that's what's
gonna happen to me at 62 too.
So I might as well be strategic now.
Anyways, nonetheless,
tonight's theme, I wanna answer questions,
I wanna talk, I wanna listen,
but the biggest thing that I would tell
is if you're smart,
and if you listen to me,
I think you can build more leverage,
and I want you to run a
marathon when it doesn't seem
like you should running a marathon,
'cause you're 42.
Does that make sense?
- Oh, I'm with you.
- Good.
That to me is the fucking juxtaposition,
where it's like,
we're fucking with 25--
- There's nothing I couldn't do at 42.
If I was to go tryout
for the New York Giants,
I'm gonna make the New York Giants at 42.
- Respect.
- 100%.
- Well, good, if you're
willing to be that ridiculous,
then my shit should be easy.
- That ridiculous?
I'm serious.
- Listen, I mean it.
If you're in that mind place, mazel tov.
Then we're set.
Because the way I'm gonna ask you to go
is way easier than making the Giants.
Just being patient as an entrepreneur.
So if you asked me what the
thing I'm most scared of,
I'm gonna very deep right now.
I'm very scared that in five years
I'm gonna get an email from a mother
who blames me for her son's suicide.
Let me explain how.
I think right now everybody
thinks they're an entrepreneur.
And we know that they're not.
But it's super easy to say
that in your Instagram.
How many times do you
guys hear somebody say,
"I'm starting a brand,"
'cause they printed five T-shirts
with a saying on it?
That them and the boys got slang term,
and they're like, "Yo, that's my brand."
Right?
Back in the day,
especially the way we grew up,
a lot of people had a hustle,
and then when it failed and they got a job
or they got married,
it just went away,
like nobody even knew.
Like, you're like, "Oh, you
remember you used to fuckin'
"try to sell ice cream on the corner?"
Now everybody's putting
their shit on blast,
saying they're gonna be the next this
and the next that.
So when they lose,
which, when the economy falls,
everyone's gonna lose,
they won't be able to hide.
Got it?
So what I thinks gonna happen,
is I think a lot of people
are gonna commit suicide.
I really do.
I'm watching it.
It's already happening.
I failed everything in school,
but there was one book,
I didn't read it,
but for some reason I got a good grade,
so it was a rare moment for me.
It was around a book
called the Scarlet Letter.
And I think about that.
By the way, I still don't know
what the book's really about,
but I know enough to know the following:
when you have a scarlet letter
and everybody can see it,
that shit is hard,
everybody's putting themselves
in a vulnerable position right now.
Everybody's a model.
Everybody's an entrepreneur.
Everybody.
And they're all be
subsidized by a fake economy.
We're old.
We know when the economy fails,
shit gets hard.
These kids are living a fake world.
And when you live in a fake world,
it's why rich kids get
into drugs problems.
They live a fake world.
Sometimes your six eight,
and that's the trick.
Other times you're super rich,
and you think you had
something to do with it.
And then you get into the real world,
and here's the problem,
this is so fun for me to talk about,
because nobody talks about the rich kid
who's gonna die.
Rich kid used to go to Harvard
'cause grandpa built the
fucking library, right?
Then he or she went to Goldman Sachs
or a law firm because grandpa did that too
and they hid in the machine,
making a million a year.
That kid now is starting a company.
But they're soft,
'cause they're a zoo animal,
'cause they were protected.
And the market doesn't give
a fuck who their grandpa was,
and they're gonna get exposed,
and they're gonna fall hard.
I meet these kids everyday.
If you ask me who I'm more scared for,
the hood kids I hang out with everyday
or the trust fund babies,
not even close,
trust fund babies.
'Cause they're gonna kill themselves.
The hood kids are just
gonna blame the President
and grind.
I'm telling you, it's gonna be bad.
You know why I'm so happy?
'Cause I think everything's my fault.
I'm being serious.
It's weird as shit.
It took me a long time.
I'm like, oh shit.
Because the second you
think it's your fault,
and you don't think anybody
else controls your shit,
you get happier.
It's real crazy shit.
I think about it all the time.
You asked a really, really smart question.
I'll tell you why.
The fine line between
confidence and insecurity,
it's super thin.
Super thin.
And all of it comes down to who are you.
God, if I could,
outside of like letting you be healthy,
like outside of me giving you a pill
that would make you healthy,
the next pill I would give you
is to get quiet.
If I tell you I don't give a fuck
what anybody says about me,
including my wife and mother,
it's true.
And that is game changing.
And that's basically all my content.
All I'm trying to do is get people,
one way or the other, to that place,
'cause what happens
then is fucking amazing.
If my mom called me right now
and said I'm disappointed in you,
I don't know what the fuck I'd do.
I talk a big game, right?
But still--
- I grew up different.
I don't care about what my mom says.
- And fair enough.
- I care what my son says.
- Respect.
Respect.
To me, whoever it is, right?
And, by the way, in the culture,
it's grandma.
For some people it's dad, not mom.
It might be your aunt.
It might be your sister.
The few times that it's
come to a head though,
there's just something
in the way I'm wired,
and raised,
and how I grew up,
I care, but I know they
don't know everything.
Got it?
Like my mom just doesn't know everything.
She knows real well,
like I was in her,
she knows me.
She really knows me.
But she doesn't know anything.
And that's what happen.
You know why I don't judge?
'Cause I don't know.
It's unbelievable.
I can't judge.
I talk a bit a lot,
but it's me making observations,
it's not judgment.
It's a very different.
A big difference.
I don't know your life.
I'll give you a good example,
I know in my heart,
that if I was homeless
I would steal every day.
I think if you're
homeless you should steal.
I actually believe that.
- It's part of survival.
- It's very simple.
Why people do what they do.
It's context.
You know?
And that's why this thing
matters to me so much.
What it comes down to every single time,
is the truth.
The biggest respect I put on a pedestal
is hiphop culture.
It's very untrickable.
It's really good at sniffing out bullshit.
There's a reason there's
something called culture vultures.
It means they got away
with it for a few minutes.
- All you need is a few
minutes in this game.
The Devil don't need no time at all.
So much money this motherfucker has,
that all it was built on.
- That's people who value
money over their name.
I lose so much money to make sure
people say nice things behind my back.
I don't give a fuck what anybody says,
yet I spend my whole life
making sure the people
that actually know me say
good things behind my back.
It's the same reason
Motown made a huge mistake
in a lot of ways.
When I look at it as a
marketing businessman,
watching current hiphop establishment
shit on mumble rap is maybe
the most interesting thing
that I've watched in a long time.
I spend ungodly amounts of time on this.
Because it's the same old shit.
It's unbelievable.
Mainly 'cause we're older now,
we're at the age where,
so Wu-Tang asked me to
be in their documentary,
it's been 25 years since
36 Chambers came out.
And I was like, "Oh my God."
When I was in college
and one of my friends
wanted me to go see The Rolling Stones,
and I was like, "The Rolling Stones?
"That's some old people shit."
That's what Wu-Tang is now
if a kid's 18 in college.
I think what you're asking,
at least what I would be thinking,
is how the fuck do you get
everybody to give a fuck
without selling out to things
that undermine the position,
is the most interesting game, right?
How do you get the youth to give a fuck?
How do you get everybody
to having the feelings?
Like when you just said
that I had feelings
from a generation ago,
I'm like this is so crazy.
- You definitely have to
get the youth to engage.
- I agree.
The problem is OGs and legends
don't do a terrible job
with respecting the youth.
- We're way different.
- I get.
- All the young audience love us.
- I believe it.
- I embrace them.
- I believe you.
- They always take
everything from our pages.
- Here's the good news.
The truth is, A, I don't know.
So we're gonna talk.
B, where I would go first,
back to the truth, that
I saw you react to it,
I'd love to know,
and, listen, you're busy
doing your own shit.
But the first place I would
start with what you're asking,
and that's what we're here to do tonight,
is who, if anybody, do you
authentically fuck with
that is young in the game right now,
and then I would start
strategizing backwards.
For the things that go completely crazy,
you need everybody to get behind,
because there's too much noise.
It's why, if you look carefully,
Jay-Z's last couple of effort,
like Jay-Z's in a funny spot.
Like nobody's saying it,
but here's the punchline.
He's a lot less relevant than
people realize right now.
Now, he's won, and it's a mogul.
- He's done.
He's got it.
- Yeah.
But if you watch carefully,
when you narrow things,
you become vulnerable.
Title was narrow,
cashed out, gave up attention.
It's fine.
Everybody's entitled to it.
- That is at the pinnacle of what we all
got in this rap game to do.
It's to fucking cash out.
- 100%.
- It wouldn't even matter
who the fuck said anything,
he's so fucking rich.
- 100%.
It depends on what you're
playing for, right?
Like, Wayne's last album,
that wasn't playing about money,
that was playing just to
have creative freedom again.
Everybody's playing for
something different always.
Everybody's fighting for something.
That's super fine.
But I'm using it as a comp,
because no matter how big you are,
eventually Madonna puts out an album
that starts the process of the downside.
On the flip side,
it's why anything can
happen on the upside.
Like people always spend
all their time worried
about the fall off,
I'm always talking about the opportunity.
It's mapping.
It's bringing value to certain people.
It's cashing in favors from others.
It's just when shit drops,
like I do, and I think
you guys even knows this,
like I give love, love, love,
but when I have a book or a sneaker,
or something I give a fuck about,
you're reconciling and
you're counting in your head,
like, you know,
and my big thing is I
ask and don't expect.
And that's why I'm also happy, right?
Like I'll hit somebody up that I knew
I did a bunch for,
and I'm like, "Yo, this
means a lot to me."
And if they don't do anything,
I'm not like, motherfuck,
my dad's the other way.
Like he's real tit for tat.
So I'm very opposite,
like I see that version.
He's like, "Yo, I fucking, back in Russia,
"I once like picked up his cow."
And like, "This motherfucker."
I'm like, "Dad, that's 39 years ago.
"You can't worry about that shit."
He's like that.
I'm the other way.
I'll give, give,
and if the person,
look, I take note.
I'm not a fucking idiot.
- Yeah, I don't want
anybody to take advantage.
I let a lot of people slide with a lot,
and I was give and don't expect.
I like helping people.
- Yeah, it's fun.
- I like genuinely helping people.
- Yo, karma's real as fuck.
Like, listen.
Negativity, the wrong thing,
it wins the halftime game.
It's leading at halftime.
But good always wins.
- A lot of people take what I've done
for a lot of negativity,
but like you said,
people don't know.
- People don't know.
- You dig?
- If something happened right now,
all they're gonna do is tell you Jim Jones
was in that restaurant with some people.
They're not gonna say nothing else,
but wherever I'm at,
they don't know.
- They don't know.
- They just tell you all the bullshit,
but they don't know what lead to that
or how it goes and shit.
You know what I mean?
- Honestly, man,
I'm telling you,
it's so liberating when you stop judging.
I look at people,
and I'm like, "You don't know."
I don't know, anyways,
so couple of things.
Let me give you something else.
Listen, this is gonna be very basic,
but I think music lives in its own cocoon.
I think about distribution.
Right? Make sense.
But I don't think about it the
way the music industry does.
For example,
what song are we gonna
give some YouTube person
to put in their vlog?
What song are we gonna
ask some E-sports kid,
while they're playing Fornite,
to play on repeat in the background?
I'll tell you that's
where Drake is very smart.
Like Drake is a marketer
as much as he is an artist.
'Cause Drake thinks about distribution.
Drake doesn't show up on
Ninja's Fornite channel for fun.
That's what I want you to do.
I want you to pick a song,
and be like this is good for teenyboppers.
This is good for E-sports people.
This is good for,
we want this playing during
the Garden, like warmups.
Got it?
Distribution,
like if you want something to pop,
you need distribution,
it doesn't make sense.
And Boyd knows this.
I always talk about Good Charlotte,
'cause I think that was the
last time I played Madden,
in like '96, '97.
When you were making your dynasty team,
Good Charlotte was playing on repeat.
You had all these kids in the hood,
they'd be like, "Yo, Good
Charlotte's fucking fresh."
I'm like, Madden.
- Well, when they put
one of my fucking records
on one of them,
I don't know if it was Madden or NBA,
one of my records was on one of them,
so that's just crazy.
Just 'cause the shit was on
one of the old games like that.
- The end.
- You're right.
That's crazy.
- Give me an example of
something that's like,
let's play here.
We're having fun.
What would be a dream scenario?
- For me it would be like--
- Someone that has like--
- Men's Health Magazine.
GQ Magazine.
- Let's talk about both.
I'm so happy right now.
Let me help you.
The reason I am who I am
is 'cause the level that
I shit on both of those.
Let me explain.
Men's Health.
GQ.
There's 53 Instagram accounts,
that if we get you on,
you'll get 50 times more
than those two things.
If you're on a cover of Men's Health,
if you get 53 of the right
influencers and meme accounts
in fitness,
you'll get way more attention.
Next.
There's 35 podcasts that will
make it way bigger than that.
Like if you ask me why companies
or big artists are losing,
is they're playing.
Guys, when GoldLink went on Fallon,
nobody fucking watched.
I don't think people get it.
I used to pray that
the Wall Street Journal
or Fast Company, or Inc.,
or the New York Times reached out to me.
Now I make them need me.
It's cat and mouse.
It's boys and girls.
Guys get the girls,
let the girl come to you.
That's what you wanna do with this.
So spending any energy trying to get them,
versus diversifying the distribution
within a digital phone environment,
I think, will give you
a lot more leverage.
I think about everything
as how many bullets
in the chamber.
That's all.
I would triple down on your audience.
Are you doing Instagram Lives at all?
- [Friend] Yes.
- Good.
How often?
It's hard.
- I do do it.
You talk to the fans too.
- Listen, I'll be very honest.
The thing that, you know,
as we've been getting to know each other,
it's the same old shit,
you get to do it with
somebody you give a fuck,
you start paying attention a little more.
I'll be honest with you.
What's more interesting for me with you,
if I became your full time manager
and we started a business together,
and this was my life,
literally the first
thing I would say to you
is 42 year old white girls.
- 42 year old white girls?
- That would be my macro
business strategy for Jim Jones.
- Meaning?
- Meaning I think--
- Reggie got those on lock.
- I think you can win that game.
I think you would win that game.
And let me tell you what about that game.
You wanna talk about real bags?
It's the bags.
Snoop's not hanging out
with Martha Stewart for fun.
And she's not hanging out
with him for fun either.
You have street cred.
It's so valuable when
the streets fuck with you
and you're mature.
The biggest advantage, I think,
of people that are in a
mature state of legend status
within hiphop,
is the streets are always
gonna fuck with you regardless.
It's kind of what that Mozzy talk,
where he really caught it.
Where I was like you can't have an album
where everything is
street, street, street,
and then that's the album.
That means you didn't
do anything to expand.
It's real great that you
got YFN Lucci in your album,
but like where's Jessica Simpson?
Where's Dolly Parton?
Where's Kate Hudson?
You see where I'm going?
- That's the only thing that you need
that'll put you in a whole
different demographic.
- Do you know much more money Nelly made
when Kelly Roland sang the hook?
Do you know what happened
to Kendrick Lamar's career
when Taylor Swift had a song with him?
It's not 1993 anymore
where everyone has to
act thug every minute.
It's about paper now.
- Yes it is.
- I think you should lean
in heavy into fitness.
And what I would do,
is I would have him DM
like 150 fitness brands;
jump ropes, bars, protein,
you know, I don't know what you fuck with.
- Everything.
- Just DM and be like--
- Fitness people do all the--
- Literally as simple as this:
keep doing your thing,
like what you're doing,
keep going.
That's it.
See who responds to that.
Fitness is your calling card.
It's not even close.
It's not even close, by the way.
It's your truth.
And that's where all the money is.
- There's a lot of money in fitness.
- Yes, in your truth.
That's where the money is.
- In my truth?
- Mm-hmm.
Do music and fitness,
tune out everything,
get focused,
get smart,
have the right meetings,
figure out where you wanna
take the fitness energy.
How do you wanna monetize?
Is it getting a million
a year to be the face
of a protein bar?
Is it selling a $100 course?
Is it getting Retro to pay
you $100,000 as an influencer?
There's a lot of ways to do it,
but first the crews gotta decide.
Tune out all the noise.
All we give a fuck about is, number one:
giving a fuck about our audience.
Once in a while replying.
Going live.
Watch what I do, not what I say.